Sonneberg mit dem Ortsteil wolkenrasen
irgendwie ein fast märchenhafter Name
der jetzt aber in ganz Deutschland
bekannt ist für den Landkreis in dem zum
ersten Mal die AFD künftig den Landrat
stellt eine Partei die seit zwei Jahren
vom Verfassungsschutz in Thüringen als
gesichert rechtsextremistisch eingestuft
wird die Empörung in den Medien ist groß
das Unverständnis auch und die anderen
Parteien zeigen alle mit dem Finger auf
den jeweils anderen war es Protest gegen
das heizungsgesetz sind die Menschen in
Sonneberg wirklich so radikal oder so
fragt sich dann der Wessi gerne ist das
nicht einfach nur typisch für den Osten
Deutschlands der erste AFD Landrat auf
der Suche nach den Ursachen unser Thema
in der Phönix Runde
[Musik]
guten Abend herzlich willkommen aus
Berlin das sind meine Gäste Anja Meyer
Journalistin und Autorin für das
focus-magazin zuvor war sie
Korrespondentin für den Weser Kurier und
lange Jahre bei der taz und sie lebt in
Brandenburg herzlich willkommen
Chefredakteur von the pioneer und der
ist in Westdeutschland aufgewachsen wenn
wir schon über Ost und West reden
Professor Astrid Lorenz ist uns
zugeschaltet Professorin für das
politische System Deutschlands und
Politik in Europa an der Universität
Leipzig und ich begrüße Professor Hans
Vorländer Parteienforscher an der
Universität Dresden dort ist der
Direktor des Zentrums für Verfassungs
und Demokratie Forschung und auch
Direktor des Mercator Forums Migration
und Demokratie Herr Brücker man hat sich
jetzt irgendwie nach diesem Wahlerfolg
in Sonneberg nach der Stichwahl wo der
afd-kandidat gewonnen hat hat man sich
so ein bisschen gefragt womit konnte
denn die AFD in Thüringen überzeugen was
denken sie
relativ offensichtlich womit sie
Wahlkampf gemacht hat nämlich mit einer
Politik gegen die Ampel in Berlin also
selbst im landratswahlkampf war das
heizungsgesetz Thema es war die grüne
Dominanz die angebliche in der
ampelthema insofern speist sich der AFD
Erfolg nicht nur in Sonneberg sondern
auch im Bund eindeutig zu einem großen
Teil zumindest durch den Unmut über die
aktuelle Bundesregierung das zeigt sich
in allen Umfragen auch 2017 war die AFD
einfach nicht so stark
2.21 hat sie noch mal zugelegt nach dem
Beginn der Ampel oder insofern natürlich
ist der Unmut über die Bundesregierung
gerade ein Treiber für die AFD egal in
welchem Stadtteil egal in welcher Stadt
aber der Landrat kann da auch nichts
dran ändern an der ampolitik aber das
ist bei den Wählern ziemlich egal weil
die das ist ein Ding Zettel die wissen
alle ganz genau wenn wir diesen AFD
Landrat wählen dann wird das
bundespolitisch diskutiert ein bisschen
zu Phoenix Hunde wird dann diskutiert
und die Leute sind nicht doof die haben
damit auch ein Zeichen setzen und gerade
wenn sich alle demokratischen Parteien
wie es ja da passiert ist dann gegen
diesen AFD Kandidaten ausgesprochen
haben war es für die erst recht eine
Möglichkeit und den Zettel zu verteilen
leider ist das passiert vor Professor
Lorenz sehen Sie das auch so das ist ja
ein sehr kleiner Landkreis 55 000
Einwohner in Deutschland geringe
Arbeitslosigkeit also nicht keine großen
Probleme eigentlich ist das jetzt ein ja
ist ein ostdeutsches Phänomen
nein weil es Ostdeutschland schon länger
nicht mehr so gibt sondern eine relativ
starker Spaltung eigentlich zwischen
Städten größeren Städten und ländlich
peripheren Regionen und das ist
Sonneberg nun mal auch und insofern ist
das vielleicht eher typisch für solche
ländlichen leicht abgehängten Regionen
die ein anderes Wahlverhalten haben sie
sehen sich einfach nicht gut politisch
repräsentiert und das hat sich schon
länger aufgebaut und insofern ist jetzt
gar nicht so eine starke Wände
eingetreten sondern das zeigt eigentlich
nur noch einmal
dass dieser Prozess schon länger im
Gange war Frau Meier würden sie dann
auch dem zustimmen was Herr Bürger sagt
dass die Landratswahl da genutzt wird um
die Kritik an der Ampel auszudrücken ja
das scheint mir auch so zu sein dass die
dass die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
ich meine ein Landrat ja den kennt man
man die hatten auch im Landrat von der
CDU und den kannten sie noch nicht so
lange der ist ja für jemand anderen
eingetragen angesprungen aber er war da
und er war auch ehrlich gesagt so viel
ich weiß auch nicht gerade
ein Mann der Mitte so dringend ja und
trotzdem haben sie den afd-mann im
ersten Wahlgang nach vorne gewählt und
dann in der Stichwahl noch mal mit einer
höheren Beteiligung noch noch
eindeutiger in dieses Amt gewesen und
das ist finde ich schon ein klares Votum
ja und auch dieses einer gegen alle das
hat nicht funktioniert oder alle gegen
einen besser gesagt Entschuldigung genau
andersrum wäre es natürlich richtig dass
man sagt die Demokraten schließen sich
zusammen um eine Person oder eine Partei
auszuschließen das hat einfach nicht
funktioniert sondern war tatsächlich
eine noch mal glaube ich eine
Aufforderung für die Wählerinnen und
Wähler und hat mich auch ein bisschen an
die 90er Jahre erinnert wo die
Ostdeutschen auch quasi die SED
überwunden haben und dann die ist die
Nachfolgepartei PDS gewählt haben also
dieses Prinzip dieses wird Prinzip
scheint mir
selber ich bin keine Wissenschaftlerin
aber das hat mich sehr stark an diese
Zeit erinnert gerade
wie erklären sie sich Frau Lorenz hat
gesagt das ist schon länger ja aufgebaut
ist es jetzt also ist das dann eine
klassische Protestwahl oder gibt's da
inzwischen weil die AFD ja über Jahre
jetzt dort auch gut gewachsen ist gerade
in Thüringen letztendlich doch
Überzeugung
ja man muss da genau hingucken natürlich
ist es so dass die AFD im Osten viel
stärker ist als im Westen sie ist im
Osten auch viel stärker verwurzelt sie
ist beispielsweise in Sachsen aber auch
in Thüringen eigentlich seit den 20 14
oder 15er Jahren ja überall präsent
sowohl in den peripheren ländlichen
Gebieten wir in den Städten und sie ist
seit 14 beispielsweise in Sachsen ja
auch im Landtag das heißt man hat sich
langsam dran gewöhnt und diese Partei
ist der Inbegriff des Widerstands der
der ostdeutschen gegen Berlin gegen die
Bundespolitik und wir wissen aus Fragen
und Befragungen auch sehr deutlich dass
die
Berliner Politik ganz generell die Ampel
jetzt noch mal zugespitzt weil einem
enormen Misstrauen getragen ist und das
wissen wir aus dem Befragung die sind
Thüringen gibt da gibt es den Thüringen
Monitor der zeigt uns sehr genau und
daneben gibt es eben auch Menschen die
Überzeugungen haben die identisch sind
mit der der AFD die sind nicht alle
rechtsextremistisch aber sie sind
populistisch sie sind also vom risseur
und Timo gegenüber Politik generell
getragen und sie sind eben auch in
manchen Hinsichten fremdenfeindlich sie
fühlen sich auch abgehängt sie fühlen
sich als Bürger zweiter Klasse das sind
alles Ergebnisse die wir den Befragung
immer wieder entnehmen können und das
kulminiert in einer solchen Situation
sozusagen und Top ist dann die Ablehnung
der Ampel und ist ja nun die Frage was
kann die Ampel kann die Ampel dann
überhaupt da was gegen Tuner Brücke
sehen Sie Punkt wo sie sagen wenn die
Ampel anders agieren würde dann hätte es
da andere Wahlergebnisse gibt ist das so
einfach nicht nur die Ampel auch die
Union aber da reden wir sicherlich
drüber weil die woher die AFD Zuwanderer
kommen also diejenigen die jetzt sagen
sie würden die AFD werden ist alles
analysiert worden da gibt's eine große
Studie da gibt's auch einen
vorsorumfrage 24% ehemalige Union aber
eben 20% ehemalige SPD 15% ehemalige FDP
das heißt da gibt es ein erheblichen
Frust in der Demokratischen Mitte über
bestimmte politische Vorgänge das sind
alles keine rechtsradikale und
rechtsextremen sonst hätten die nicht
vorher CDU SPD oder FDP gewählt würde
ich jetzt mal mutmaßen ich würde es mal
mutmaßen ist 10% gibt es vielleicht aber
nicht 20 Prozent wo wir heute liegen
also insofern wenn einer Ampel eine
klare verantwortungsvolle kommunikativ
saubere ruhige Politik machen würde
übrigens hat sie das in den ersten
Monaten in der Ukraine Krise im
energieumfeld auch gemacht dann gäbe es
diesen Aufschwung nicht und wenn die
Union eine klare Linie fahren würde was
sie auch nicht tut gäbe es diesen auch
schon wahrscheinlich auch nicht sondern
dann gab es einen harten schlimmen
traurigen tragischen Kern am rechten in
diesem Land der aber nicht bei 20 %
machen die Ampel und auch die Union die
anderen Parteien tatsächlich
verantwortlich wir sagen immer 10%
dieser Welle auf jeden Fall wir hatten
2017 einen Höhepunkt hat jeder zehnte
wahlberechtigte die AFD gewählt ganz
eindeutig von allen Analysen
flüchtlingskrise da gab es ganz viele
Humanität ganz wenig Ordnung also gab es
diese Aufschwung für die AFD danach ist
der zurückgegangen es gab keine
Landtagswahl mehr keine Regionalwahl wo
die zugelegt haben
aber nach zwei 21 sind sie jetzt auf 20%
hoch oder sonst würden wir gar nicht
diskutieren hervorländern also 2017 war
die AFD die stärkste Partei bei der Wahl
das fing mit der Europa also in Sachsen
Moment
das heißt wir haben mittlerweile ein
Plateau auf dem die AFD ist und wenn man
dann besondere Umstände haben so wie
jetzt die die Ablehnung der Ampel
Politik dann kommt das sozusagen noch
oben drauf und die Sonneberg wie erlaubt
in einigen Regionen in Ostdeutschlands
haben wir ganz besondere Voraussetzungen
Bedingungen die dazu führen dass eben
Kandidaten der AFD sehr wohl wählbar
erscheinen wir haben ja schon bei
Landtagswahlen im letzten Jahr haben wir
schon auch in Sachsen aber auch wieder
in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern solche
Konstellation gehabt wo es wirklich
spitz auf Knopf stand und wo sich alle
gegen den afd-kandidaten oder die
Kandidaten zu einer Allianz
zusammengefunden haben und da ging es
noch mal gut in diesmal ist es nicht gut
gegangen also wir haben Konstellationen
die wir schon kennen aus den vergangenen
Jahren von Lorenz was wird sich denn
dann ändern jetzt wenn es ein AFD
Landrat gibt bisher ist die AFD ja so
nicht in politischer Verantwortung was
würde man kann sich dann konkret ändern
das ist ja ein Verwaltungsamt das heißt
so viel wird sich jetzt nicht ändern man
wird noch mal feststellen wie viele
Dinge vorgegeben sind nach konkreten
Arbeit einer Kommune bzw eines
Landkreises man wird auch sehen wie sehr
man abhängig ist von den
finanziellen Zuweisungen natürlich kann
man nicht die Europolitik ändern und die
allgemeine Migrationspolitik das wird
man auch feststellen und insofern wird
da neue Landrat sehr schnell auf dem
Boden der Tatsachen auch kommen aber es
ist natürlich nicht ausgeschlossen dass
da nicht alles gleich kollabiert sondern
dass der Landkreis auch normal geführt
wird und dann ist er die Frage wie
reagieren die Bürgerinnen und Bürger und
auch die anderen Parteien wenn jetzt
nicht sofort
alles den Bach runtergeht das ist viel
schwieriger also die Normalisierung
einer afd-politik die Normalisierung
oder halt eben auch die sozusagen der
Praxis checkt der dann ja kommen muss
also dann ist dann ist er der
Realitätscheck da und dann kann man
vielleicht manche Dinge nicht so
umsetzen die man vorher kritisiert hat
ja also das glaube ich würde eher der
AFD in die Karten spielen weil sie ja
behaupten könnte bei jeder Gelegenheit
der Landrat das irgendwas nur nicht
klappt weil die anderen Parteien im über
mitspielen und nicht reinlassen und
deshalb nur Geld nicht kommt oder
ähnliches also das sehe ich jetzt gar
nicht so das ist so
leicht jetzt wäre quasi die AFD zu dem
maskieren sondern im Gegenteil es könnte
auch umgekehrt sein dass einfach dann
weiter von der AFD behauptet wird sie
wird ausgegrenzt und nur deshalb weil
jemanden AFD Parteibuch hat wird fließt
kein Geld oder mit einer Schule
geschlossen oder ähnlich ist
[Musik]
das sinnvoll jetzt also Sie haben es ja
eben schon gesagt die anderen Parteien
haben sich zusammengetan bei dieser
Stichwahl um eben gemeinsam sagen wir
alle da gegen den afd-kandidaten macht
das Sinn diese Art der Politik
vorzusetzen oder muss man jetzt wo es
jemand wo jemand die Mehrheit hat und
gewählt ist anders damit umgehen ich
glaube dass alle Parteien also und zwar
von der Bundesebene bis in die bis in
die Länder jetzt fragen müssen wie sie
sich verhalten wollen denn das hat ja
jetzt schon mal nicht geklappt ja und es
ist wirklich eine große Frage was die
was sie tun wollen also man sieht dass
wenn alle zusammenhalten werden sie
ununterscheidbar also dann sind sie
erscheinen sozusagen die die Parteien
der Mitte sage ich jetzt mal als
monolitischer Block die sich nur gegen
etwas stellen und nicht sagen was sie
eigentlich also wofür sie eigentlich
stehen und dann wird es schwierig und
ich bin da ganz
ratlos gerade also ich bin der Kollege
Brücke und ich wir sind ja auch hier in
Berlin unterwegs und ich glaube auch
dieser Fragen bei jeder Gelegenheit
jedem
spitzenparteipolitiker und Palette
parteipolitikerin was ist denn ihr Plan
und es gibt keinen bis jetzt und äh also
man kann es wirklich mit Händen greifen
die Ratlosigkeit die da gerade steht
gerade erst irgendwie in den Bundestag
und den Landtag gekommen
ich glaube vor zwei Wochen ganz guten
analytischen Text im Spiegel zum
Beispiel wo ein
Stratege der AFD gefragt wurde wie das
ist denn ihre Strategie für die für die
Landtagswahl der wir gucken einfach was
die Grünen machen und behaupten das
Gegenteil ganz einfach ja und wir
brauchen wir brauchen keine Strategie
wir sind einfach nur dagegen und
natürlich kann man sagen in der in der
Praxis wird sowas auch irgendwie an sein
Ende kommen also dieser Landrat hat ja
glaube ich keine Mehrheit im Kreistag
und der wird schon auch irgendwie
verhandeln müssen aber trotzdem ist es
die große Frage ich sehe im Moment noch
keine Ansätze für eine echte Strategie
wohl also die muss ja seinen Menschen
wieder zurückzuholen zu anderen Parteien
genau was würden Sie sagen was würden
Sie jetzt der Union raten
also um halt eben Menschen wieder von
der AFD zurück zu gewinnen was wäre
wichtig
sie muss im Bund ihre Oppositionsrolle
finden das ist der glaube ich das größte
Problem in der Regel ist es ja so wenn
es eine Koalition gibt die in der
Regierung ist die eine Politik macht die
allgemein auch Widerstand stößt dann ist
es die vornehmste Rolle der größten
Oppositionspartei die Alternative
darzustellen zur Regierungspolitik
Alternativen
sein vor allen Dingen auch jetzt nicht
der AFD noch mal bei den Themen
nachlaufen das halte ich für relativ für
ganz verkehrt sondern sie muss zeigen
dass sie die bessere Politik
verkörpert und dass sie eben die
wirkliche Alternative zu den
Koalitionsparteien
sich eher nach rechts zu bewegen oder
eher in die Mitte März hat ja gesagt
unser Hauptgegner sind die Grünen das
richtig ja aber das sagt die AFD ja auch
wie schon gesagt worden ist da kann man
da kann man sozusagen nicht in die
Konkurrenz treten das das ist verloren
weil dann immer das origin Jahre
gewählt wird und vor allen Dingen auch
weil das Thema die Themen
Agenda der AFD hier aufgewertet und
Mobilität wird die wird sozusagen in die
Mitte der Gesellschaft hineingeholt ich
glaube dass dagegen hilft nicht sondern
man muss eben zeigen dass man eine
bessere klimawandelpolitik betreibt und
was die Konzepte sind dafür ich glaube
das wäre das das entscheidende damit
dass sie zum Beispiel sagt Klimawandel
gibt's nicht und wir wollen all diese
ganze Energiewende nicht damit Punkte
sie verlangen etwas von der Union was
wirklich nicht machbar ist sie haben
gerade gesagt sie soll eine Opposition
entwickeln zur Ampel also müsste sie
dagegen sein also müsste sie gegen einen
grünen dominiertes heizungsgesetz sein
ist aber die AFD auch sie müsste
vielleicht sogar in der Migration sozial
und Finanzpolitik gegen zentrale Ampel
sein ist die AFD aber manchmal leider
auch also die Frage dagegen zu sein und
trotzdem konstruktiv zu sein ist
übrigens schwierig übrigens ist sie
nämlich konstruktiv 100 von 188
Initiativen der Ampel hat die Union
mitgetragen ob wir da also bei der Union
irgendwie den scharfen kantigen
oppositionswahlkampf sieht den gibt es
gar nicht die Union war die Union weiß
nicht was sie will die weiß nicht was
sie will und nur weil die AFD ein Thema
bei ihren Wählern ganz oben hat z.B
Migration heißt das nicht dass ich das
als größte Oppositionspartei nicht
machen darf im Gegenteil das ich will
nur sagen dass dieses migrationsthema
ist bei jedem Landrat auch bei grünen
Land treten das Thema Nummer eins und
nur weil es die AFD plakatiert soll die
Oppositionspartei sich dazu nicht klar
aussehen dürfen natürlich im Gegenteil
Politik aber bei dem Thema führt ja eher
dazu dass die AFD gewinnt und ich kann
auch nicht als Union dann sagen naja
aber dann werden sie das Original
deswegen Sprache ich das Thema Migration
mal aus also so einfach ist es leider
nicht dagegen
meine Meinung also weil ich sehe das
nämlich auch so die die Union macht im
Parlament im Bundestag eine sehr
engagierte
Oppositionspolitik auch fachlich finde
ich also auch zum Beispiel bei der
wärmepolitik bei der Energiepolitik bei
der Friedenspolitik also die haben sich
da nach anfänglichem großen Geheule
super eingefunden ja so was ich aber der
Unterschied den ich wahrnehme ist die
der Ton die Tonlage die eskaliert gerade
das und das ist eigentlich eine Person
nämlich der Partei und
Fraktionsvorsitzende Friedrich Merz der
reitet das Pferd der AFD gerade und ich
finde die Partei ist ja gerade wirklich
mitten in so einem Prozess sie schreiben
an ihrem Programm und und ich habe
gerade das Gefühl die sind inhaltlich
entleert sozusagen wissen nicht wer sie
sind das haben sie gerade auch gerade
gesagt äh und machen jetzt einfach was
der Chef sagt es gibt keine Stärke in
der Mitte dieser Partei ist ist das
verloren ist es das wenn die CDU stärker
weiß wo sie hin will ob sie was weiß ich
mehr nach rechts will oder mehr in den
in die Mitte würde das helfen Menschen
zu überzeugen dass sie sagen ja ich
mache mein Kreuz dann lieber bei der CDU
wie sehen Sie das
ja ein bisschen ist da immer was zu
holen weil eben grundsätzlich viele
Menschen nicht an einer bestimmte Partei
gebunden sind also ich will das nicht
ausschließen aber letztendlich besteht
ja das Problem strukturell also man muss
an die strukturellen Probleme ran man
muss da rein dass die Menschen eben
nicht
angebunden sind an die Kanäle der
Interessen Repräsentation ob das nun
Gewerkschaften Kirchen oder Parteien
sind dass Ihre Interessen nicht richtig
eingespeist werden das bestimmte Dinge
nicht so richtig gut funktionieren in
den ländlich peripheren Räumen und das
sind doch Dinge die viele interessieren
also in unserer Forschung haben wir
gefragt was sind denn für Sie die
wichtigen Themen und da haben uns viele
Menschen gesagt in diesem Gebieten es
ist Gesundheit es ist sicher Sicherheit
und es ist Bildung und soziale Themen
das sind ja so ganz klassische Themen
und da ist zum Beispiel jetzt aus meiner
Sicht viel wichtiger was in den nächsten
Monaten passiert in Bezug auf die
krankenhausreform das beschäftigt sehr
viele Menschen in diesen Regionen dass
das Krankenhaus sterben nicht weitergeht
und das heizungsgesetz wird als viel
weniger wichtig erachtet weil allgemein
das Thema Umwelt als weniger erachtet
wird und deshalb soll man das jetzt
nicht natürlich liegen lassen aber sich
dessen doch Bewusstsein dass in
bestimmten Räumen gerade völlig andere
themenrelevant sind
jetzt gibt es Umfragen sie haben auch
schon Untersuchungen angesprochen des
Leipziger else Franke brunsiek Instituts
da gibt es eine ganze Reihe von von
ähm folgen und eine ist
77%, also in Ostdeutschland sagen sie
hätten keinen Einfluss darauf was die
Regierung tut und 64% sagen ich halte es
für sinnlos mich politisch zu engagieren
da fragt man sich ja wie konnte das
passieren der Vorländer aber das ist ja
sehen wir auch schon seit vielen Jahren
noch nicht sozusagen seit jahrzehn das
ist genau der populistisch Reflex was
die da oben machen das geht an unseren
Interessen vorbei und das ist äh eine
ganz bestimmte Eliten kritische
Einstellung und deshalb werden eben auch
von der AFD genau diese Themen so
gesetzt das andere sind eben die
kartellparteien die sich jetzt auch noch
zusammenschließen gegen die AFD das ist
sozusagen die Sprache der AFD die
Altparteien und die verkörpern das ist
teppichment und regieren an uns vorbei
das ist sozusagen die Grundstimmung und
die können mir seit vielen Jahren immer
wieder so beobachten insofern ist dieses
Ergebnis jetzt nichts Besonderes
länger laufen zu lassen sorry ich bin
auch nicht dafür aber es ist so
heizungsgesetz zwei Drittel der
Deutschen finden es so einfach nicht
richtig zu schnell zu hart und bei der
Migration sagen auch zwei Drittel dass
wir davon sehen
die AFD nährt sich durch Eliten
Verdrossenheit Medien
Politikverdrossenheit und wenn wir immer
wieder egal bei welcher Bundesregierung
zentrale Themen gegen die Mehrheit der
Menschen entscheiden sie können ja
trotzdem richtig sein aber muss man sich
nicht wundern dass ich irgendwie eine
Form des Protests gesucht wird ist doch
klar
Followern würden sie das auch so sehen
dass sie sagen das ist so klar es geht
um Eliten und um die anderen weil nicht
alle entscheiden sich ja so ich würde ja
also ich würde sagen dass die
Einschätzung dass man mit bestimmten
Positionen die abweichen sich nicht
durchsetzen kann also nicht
seine eigene Handschrift in der
Regierung hinterlassen kann ist ja
realistisch weil nun mal manche
Positionen sehr stark abweichen und
nicht dem Grundkonsens damit die Politik
in Deutschland entsprechen insofern ist
die Einschätzung durchaus ja richtig das
bestimmte Positionen nicht mehr als
fähig sind und ähm es ist ja tatsächlich
so dass die Regierungsparteien im Bund
im Osten nur von ungefähr 42% der Wähler
gewählt wurden also eine Mehrheit hat
zum Osten nicht und wenn wir jetzt
wieder in die ländlich Piri fernräume
gehen dann ist es dort ja sehr viel
niedriger noch der Anteil Fehler weil ja
zum Beispiel die SPD in den größeren
Städten in Ostdeutschland ja durchaus
starker gewählt wurde als in den
ländlichen Räumen und bei den Grünen ist
es ja der Unterschied noch viel stärker
und insofern ist das auch realistisch zu
sagen wenn wenn solche abweichenden
Positionen vertreten wurden dass man da
nicht regiert das ist ja in Bayern mit
der CDU jetzt auch genauso die werden
auch nicht alle AFD also das ist richtig
aber da hat man dann oft eine
Landesregierung die kompensiert diese
dieses dass man nicht abgebildet ist und
in Thüringen funktioniert es eben nicht
da hat man eine Regierung aus linke und
anderen Parteien die natürlich jetzt
nicht in Opposition stehen zur
Bundesregierung also da könnte jetzt die
CDU natürlich die Gunst der Stunde
nutzen und sich profilieren um hier zu
kompensieren aber die Einschätzung dass
man nicht regiert ist ja
realistisch ja das hieß ja dann von
Bayern lernen wir dann das Richtige also
in dem Fall an die Grünen
Ventil
es gibt einen ein kleines Ventil und man
versucht immer das Ventil und wenn eben
das Misstrauen gegenüber der Politik und
vor allen Dingen der zentralstaatlichen
in Berlin gemachten Politik so groß ist
dann wird sich eben immer die Partei als
Siegerin nicht nur empfinden sondern
auch bei dem Wahltag herausstellen die
genau das aufnimmt und diese Stimmung
werden eben von der AFD systematisch
aufgenommen auch noch mal befeuert und
dann kommt ebenso etwas heraus und
deshalb hat eben auch der Kandidat das
ist immer in Sonneberg diesen Wahlkampf
so gemacht hat und das war und das war
erfolgreich und das wird auch das Rezept
sein bei den Landtagswahlen im nächsten
Jahr deswegen wünsche ich mir uns um das
auch die Grünen schauen in ihren
analysezentren in der
Bundesgeschäftsstelle was Sie vielleicht
falsch gemacht haben damit sowas
passiert genauso wie die Union wie die
SPD das ist wirklich eine Frage an alle
demokratischen Parteien der Mitte wie
was sie beigetragen haben um die so groß
zu machen und trotzdem war die DVU auch
mein sieben Landtagen und die
Republikaner auch und die gibt's heute
nicht mehr man darf es auch nicht
überbewerten das kann auch nächstes Jahr
wieder ganz anders aussehen bei den
Grünen erleben wir doch gerade zurzeit
dass die sozusagen so ein bisschen mehr
kooper machen und sich einsichtig zeigen
und so also das ähm vor dem Hintergrund
dass Sie wissen das nächstes Jahr die
Landtagswahl im Osten sind und mit
diesen Ergebnissen gehen sie ins
Bundestagswahl ja also das ist einfach
klar so geht es nicht weiter aber wie
gesagt ich sehe keinerlei Ansätze bis
jetzt aber trotzdem noch mal die Frage
wenn es eben dann doch so viel andere
Ergebnisse auch in Ostdeutschland geht
was ich eben ja auch so viele die sagen
ist egal was ich mache ich habe ja eh
keine Möglichkeit mich politisch zu
beteiligen aber andere Ergebnisse sind
auch wo mehr als 20 Prozent
sagen halt eben ohne Judenvernichtung
könnte man Hitler als großen Staatsmann
ansehen oder knapp 70 Prozent sagen die
Ausländer kommen nur hier unseren
Sozialstaat auszunutzen
ist es dann doch da die Überzeugung
einfach anders verlorens oder noch mal
wir sollten einen Führer haben der
Deutschland zum Wohle aller mit starker
Hand regiert sagen 14 Prozent teilweise
zustimmen bei weiteren
19%, also das wenn ich das lese denke
ich es kann jetzt nicht an der Ampel
alleine liegen der muss irgendwie noch
was anderes sein
erklären Sie es mir genauso ist es das
ist so ich finde man bräuchte eigentlich
eine gute Auswertung nach Siedlungsort
und nicht nur nach Bundesländern wie es
gemacht wurde
um noch besser zu verstehen was dahinter
steht wir wissen ja schon dass es nicht
unbedingt Menschen sind die nur die
weniger gebildet sind oder sozial
schwächer die solche Einstellungen haben
man muss das besser verstehen und eben
etwas tun und das kann nur langfristig
geschehen und das hat sich so lange
aufgebaut wir sehen das in so vielen
Umfragen seit Jahren dass man eben auch
nicht das schnell ändern kann und es
reicht nicht einfach nur eine
parteistrategie zu ändern oder eine
rhetorisches Strategie da gehört ganz
viel dazu es gehört davor dazu sichtbar
zu sein in den Regionen es geht darum
dass man die Menschen auch irgendwie
abbildet in den Diskursen dass sie
selber erkennen ja Nachrichten und
ien und so weiter viele sagen die AFD
ist so ein bisschen zu der Kümmerer
Partei geworden also wenn die Menschen
da Probleme haben was weiß ich mit ihren
Formularen mit bestimmten Dingen dann
wäre es Leute der AFD die dann helfen
und weniger die anderen ist das eine
Einschätzung die sie teilen
ja sie sind da vor Ort und es
unterstützen ja auch und bieten sich
Leute da AFD an aktiv zu sein die die
AFD manchmal ja auch gar nicht noch
nicht mal selber will das sind einfach
Leute die man vor Ort oft kennt und das
ist bei einigen anderen Parteien eben
nicht der Fall die das Problem haben
obwohl sie auch Nachwuchs suchen und
Leute die mitmachen dass sie da nicht
auf offene Ohren stoßen und das das
Problem das muss einfach behoben werden
sonst wird es immer so sein dass
bestimmte Interessen untere präsentiert
sind und Menschen sagen wir sind nicht
abgebildet sie haben ja dann auch recht
aber Sie müssen sich auch selber
Einbringen in die in die Parteien und da
Ihre Wünsche vertreten
jedes Mal verzweifeln lässt ist das
eigentlich dieses da die müssen da
sichtbar sein die müssen da mitmachen
die Leute müssen mitmachen können und
sich gesehen fühlt es wird eigentlich
nach jeder Landtagswahl und jeder
Bundestagswahl gemacht also jede Partei
mir fällt da jetzt die SPD in
Brandenburg ein wo ich lebe sagt dann
aber ab jetzt ja sind wir aber sowas von
da ja wir werden dort ein Büro eröffnen
und so weiter und es ist es versickert
einfach wieder natürlich auch weil die
Parteien gar nicht die Leute haben das
wirklich zu tun ja und bei der bei der
AFD
hallo wir würden gerne Plakate hacken
also da sieht man einfach die
mobilisierungsmöglichkeit und die
Anschlussfähigkeit und dann reden wir
vor allem über den ländlichen Raum aber
deswegen ist auch aus meiner Sicht nicht
das Rezept wir müssen jetzt in den
Partei Gliederungen unten noch bessere
Volksfeste organisieren und bessere
Hüpfburgen aufbauen weil wir vor uns
sind vertrauen sie haben es doch gerade
selber gesagt von uns das Vertrauen in
alle etablierten demokratischen Parteien
ist wirklich minimal das Vertrauen dass
diese Politiker nicht an ihre eigenen
Interessen denken dass sie vernünftige
maßvolle Politik machen mit einem klaren
Ziel und wenn das passiert dann hat die
AFD noch gar keine gar keinen
Angriffsfläche mehr und das gilt für
alle Parteien
das ist richtig aber wir wissen aus der
Forschung ja das Vertrauen das ist ja
sehr abstrakt die Leute entwickeln nicht
vertrauen abstrakt in irgendwelche
Institutionen sondern es wird immer
vermittelt über Personen den man
vertraut das ist also gut gesichert das
Wissen und das ist einfach notwendig
dass diese Personen auch vor Ort sind
und ja es wurde oft sich vorgenommen wir
machen das jetzt anders und es ist auch
schwer mit wenig Personen da von vor Ort
zu sein es muss aus der
lokalen Gesellschaft selber kommen aus
Sonneberg selber und das anderen Orten
dass die Mitte der Gesellschaft die
gemäßigten dass sie sehen ja es braucht
uns und wir nehmen hier mal unser
Schicksal in die Hand
weg war der beliebteste Politiker
Deutschlands vor einem Jahr der
beliebteste Politiker Deutschlands die
Grünen war 23 Prozent der war jetzt
nicht vor Ort sondern der war einfach da
und er hat sehr viel richtig gemacht und
ist heute Platz 6 7 8 und sein
heizungsgesetz wurde in Bausch und Bogen
von der Mehrheit der Deutschen
kritisiert es hat leider oft auch mit
der Bundespolitik zu tun und diesen
t unterwegs
gerade in Thüringen bei der AFD sieht
wie Björn höcke der nun wirklich jemand
ist der wirklich radikal ist ja voll
denn wie kann das sein dass Menschen der
ihm dann vertrauen
ja weil er auch Sonneberg kommt der ist
dort geboren ist er war auch der
Kandidat der der CDU und er hat eine
erfolgreiche Anwaltskanzlei und ist
einfach
Präsentation
aber dass man auch sagt eine Partei wo
jemand hier höcke in der ersten Reihe
steht ja ich glaube die Sachen laufen ja
anders weil die sich im anbieten als als
Ventil des Widerstands die organisieren
ihn Widerstand ja das ist eine
Widerstands Rhetorik die dort seit
Jahren eingeübt und praktiziert wird
deswegen auf der Straße an bei den
großen Demonstrationen von pegida wo er
nachher alle Widerstand Riefen und hat
sich die AFD draufgesetzt und gerade die
Thüringer mit der mit der Unterstützung
auch von Google schick und anderen haben
das ganz genau ausgewertet und haben
genau ihre Strategie darauf gesetzt und
das gelingt ihn immer wieder wir vor
allen Dingen in den Peripherien auch der
der größeren Städte aber in den
ländlichen Regionen wo es ohnehin schon
ein Gewissen Widerstandsgeist gibt der
haben sich aus kleinen
gewerbliche mittelständischen
Eigensinn ergibt der sich auch aus ganz
bestimmten geographischen Randlagen
ergibt Sonneberg liegt im talen
Grenzgebiet zu früher an der Zonengrenze
heute an der Grenze zu Bayern
das ist sozusagen auch ein Gefälle
außerdem hat haben diese Städte alle
auch die gesamte Osten eine enorme
Transformation durchgemachten das kommt
ja noch mit hinzu wenn also die Menschen
das Argument ist ja dann auch richtig
was vorgetragen wurde wenn die Menschen
sind dort geschafft haben vielleicht
Grund und Boden wieder zu haben haben
wir Häuschen eingerichtet haben eine
Heizung installiert und jetzt sollen sie
auf einmal nach 10 20 Jahren schon
wieder alles rausschneiden aber das ist
eigentlich schwer zu vermitteln aber
die afd-wähler bei der letzten
Bundestagswahl in Sonneberg wir haben
gesagt dass sie eine 73 Prozent der ARD
Wähler haben bei der letzten
Bundestagswahl gesagt dass ihre
wirtschaftliche Situation gut sei und
auch in Sonneberg ist die
Arbeitslosenquote ja sehr niedrig und
geht es den Menschen ja nicht aber sie
sagen gleichzeitig immer die eigene
Situation ist gut aber wenn es darum
geht die allgemeine Situation
einzuschätzen dann sagen 80% ist es
schlecht das heißt sozusagen die
Zukunftserwartung auf die Zukunft
Ängste die sind sehr stark und das ist
auch normal das Angst Momentum gehört
auch mit zum Erfolgsrezept das
aufzugreifen noch zuzuspitzen was die
AFD dann sehr systematisch entfaltet sie
haben gewittert wir Medien sind bei der
Berichterstattung über die AFD seit
Jahren von druckst feige und zum Teil
verlogen ich auch was meinen Sie denn
damit ja wir haben ja genau wie Frau
Meiers eben gesagt hat ähnlich wie die
Politik noch nicht den richtigen Umgang
gefunden mit der AFD ich spreche jetzt
für uns als med und und will gar nicht
über andere reden mit wem machen wir die
Interviews wie machen wir die Interviews
jetzt die Riesen Debatte über das
sternkammer mit Alice Weidel wo haben
wir denn die afd-politiker wirklich
gestellt in welchen Interviews ich kenne
sehr viele Medien auch wir halten uns
sehr zurück mit Interviews mit
afd-politikern weil wir in einerseits
nicht die Bühne geben wollen für ihre
Propaganda die schlimm ist die
rechtsradikal ist und auf der anderen
Seite müssten wir sie doch eigentlich
stellen weil sie demokratisch gewählte
Parteien sind und unsere Auftrag ist ein
Journalisten ist sie zu stellen und
offenzulegen wie sie wirklich ticken und
ich finde da gab es viel Zickzack bei
uns auch und ich glaube deswegen wenn
wir auf die Politik schauen mit mit der
Hand schaut immer auch eine oder zwei
Finger wieder zurück auf uns Medien auch
wir müssen konsequent kritisch mit einer
klaren demokratischen Haltung natürlich
aber eben auch mit der AFD anders
umgehen und auch mit ihnen ähm Ringen
diskutieren Interviews führen
wahrscheinlich haben wir da in den
letzten Jahren viel falsch gemacht sonst
werden sie nicht da
Ignoranz und Ausgrenzung die wir auch
gerade mal die machen wir auch wir bei
uns machen die hat leider nicht dazu
geführt dass nicht jetzt doch die AFD
bei fünf oder sechs Prozent in den
Umfang nicht sondern bei 20 Prozent wir
haben es ja nicht hingekriegt Frau Meier
wollen sie das auch sagen dass man Herrn
höcke eine Bühne bieten sollte zum
Beispiel stärker also ehrlich gesagt
nicht ich finde das Alice Weidel ist die
Fraktionsvorsitzende im Deutschen
Bundestag die hätte ich vielleicht jetzt
nicht gerade als sie will es ist immer
schwierig über Kollegen und so schnell
also sie zu kritisieren aber ich hätte
sie vielleicht nicht auf den Titel
genommen das das muss nicht sein das ist
eine Bühne die sozusagen das feiert sie
so aber es ist quasi Poster Journalismus
aber das man mit
afd-politikerin und Politikerin redet
und auch ich finde z.B das Format das
Streitgespräch sehr gut also der
sozusagen gar nicht nur interviewen und
Politikerin sondern auch Antipoden
politische Antipoden quasi miteinander
um die besseren Ideen bringen zu lassen
das finde ich schon richtig und ich
glaube
dann auch in der zum Beispiel den
Position des Bundestags Vizepräsidenten
für jemand von der AFD das ist ja immer
noch markant das ist immer noch vakant
ja ich sehe die Schmerzen der AFD dabei
ja ich sehe habe aber auch gesehen dass
es einen afd-politiker ich glaube im
Auswärtigen Ausschuss gab der der
unglaubliches da verzapft hat und wieder
raus in dem Rechtsausschuss
Entschuldigung Rechtsausschuss und der
dann quasi wieder
rausgeführt wurde weil er einfach
wirklich Demokratie schädigen sich
verhalten hat im Deutschen Bundestag ich
meine das ist da guckt die ganze Welt
drauf ja also Deutschland nach außen bei
Bundespolitiker aber ganz im Ernst er
muss sich seine eigene Mehrheit im
Parlament dann auch holen für das Amt
des Bundes er hat kein Anrecht darauf
keinen demokratisches er muss gewählt
werden wenn er das nicht wird dann muss
er damit auch leben
sie sagen was würden sie auch jetzt hier
den Kollegen oder uns Kollegen von den
Medien sagen was ist gut damit wir ja
unsere Demokratie weiter stärken in dem
Sinne und eben damit einander besser ins
Gespräch kommen und auch mit mehr
Verständnis für vielleicht Positionen
der Wählerinnen und Wähler
ja ich glaube es man muss gar nicht nur
darüber nachdenken wie man mit der AFD
umgeht sondern wie mit man mit Menschen
aus den Regionen in denen der AFD stark
gewählt wird umgeht die müssen
abgebildet werden das muss ja gar nicht
unbedingt die AFD nur sein also dass sie
dir einfach das Gefühl haben dass ihre
Themen die Sie interessieren auch
abgebildet sind das scheint mir
eigentlich noch viel wichtiger als
jemand mit der AFD umgeht und da gibt es
ja große Unterschiede nach AFD auf
welcher Ebene ich finde z.B das auch
Journalisten und Journalisten ja auch
aus den ländlich peripheren Räumen ein
paar gibt's ja noch ähm dass sie auch
mal abgebildet sein könnten in solchen
Diskursen leider haben wir ja das
Zeitungssterben auch und viele Menschen
erreichen auch in diesen Gebieten gar
nicht mehr
Qualitätsjournalismus Zeitung waren
nicht mehr ausgeliefert weil sich nicht
lohnt und so das muss man alles mitsehen
dass sie auch die Lebensbedingungen und
Arbeitsbedingungen auch für guten
Journalismus ja in diesen Regionen auch
nicht gerade so gut sind
gestern Abend bei einer Lesung Dirk
Oschmann der dieses Buch geschrieben hat
der Osten eine westdeutsche Erfindung
hervor in der lacht aber da ging es auch
stark um Gefühle das war man hat es
gemerkt dass die Leute
regelrecht dankbar waren das überhaupt
über sie gesprochen wird und das quasi
jemand sich hinstellt und sagt ja ich
verstehe das wir müssen immer erklären
dass ein die einen sind das normale und
wir sind sozusagen das andere und das
müssen und jedes Mal wenn wir den Mund
aufmachen mit einer ostdeutschen
Erfahrung müssen wir erklären dass wir
uns natürlich vom vom Unrechtsstaat
distanzieren und erstmal drei
Erklärungen abgeben bevor wir gucken
aber
[Gelächter]
das ist ganz klar das ist glaube ich
auch dem Autor dieses Buch ist
vollkommen klar dass das absolutes
Reizthema ist aber was ich sagen will
ist man hat es im Publikum auch an den
Fragen des Publikums gemerkt das waren
alles jetzt die kam nicht aus ihren
Tälern die kam aus ihren vor orthäuschen
und aus ihren Prenzlauer Berger
parkettwohnungen und die waren begierig
ihre Geschichten zu erzählen und das ist
wirklich wenn sie sagen frau Lorenz
sozusagen die die Lebenswirklichkeit
abzubilden sie überhaupt sichtbar zu
machen da also da hat der absoluten
Punkt der Herr Oschmann und dieses
Bedürfnis ist sehr stark also so viel
vielleicht auch zu Medien
oder würden Sie sagen weil sie jetzt
gelacht haben also würden Sie sagen es
ist dann tatsächlich hat doch was damit
zu tun mit mehr mit Ostdeutschland die
sich da nicht gesehen fühlen ist das so
ja da werden ja Identitäten auch wieder
neue konstruiert die sogenannte
ostdeutsche Identität ist ja erst ein
Produkt seit 20 14 15 in der beginnt man
überhaupt sich erst aus deutscher zu
definieren auch im öffentlichen im doch
im öffentlichen im öffentlichen
Räume und natürlich am Anfang nicht
vertreten war in diesem Diskus groß und
ich weiß das noch ganz genau 14:15 Uhr
als pegida in Dresden anfingen da waren
westdeutsche Medien dort und für die
waren das alles
Neonazis oder kosten natürlich gab es da
rechtsextreme und Rechtsextremisten
dabei gerade bei den Organisatoren aber
die Menschen die damals auf die Straße
gehen die suchten nach einer Möglichkeit
ihr Gefühl nicht gehört zu sein zu
wenden und eine Stimme zu gewinnen und
das ist das entscheidende das ist
sozusagen das Oschmann Prinzip was er
sozusagen jetzt noch mal auf die Spitze
treibt über 30 Jahre nach der Wende ein
bisschen spät aber das ist so ein
Versuch sozusagen aus Deutschland ist
eine Stimme zu geben weil die die
Stimmung verbreitet ist dass man immer
als Bürger zweiter Klasse behandelt
worden ist ob das nun stimmt oder nicht
ist eine ganz andere Frage aber das ist
sozusagen die Grundbefindlichkeit und
das Grundrauschen und darauf setzt
natürlich früher hat die Linke versucht
das sozusagen aufzufangen hat aber
verloren und jetzt ist die AFD diejenige
die das genau zu mobilisieren versteht
und verknüpft mit solchen
Widerstandsaktionen gegen das
heizungsgesetz oder gegen die Migration
und und und das sind beides sozusagen
sich wechselseitige natürlich auch die
Kollegen der Bild-Zeitung extrem
Stimmung gemacht aber das macht doch
nicht also ob die ob jetzt die
Bild-Zeitung den heizhammer als Wort
erfindet oder ob zwei Drittel der
Deutschen der Meinung sind es kommt zu
früh ich verstehe es nicht und ich kann
es mir nicht leisten sind für mich zwei
paar Schuhe nimm mal die Bild-Zeitung
raus komplett aus dem Diskurs dann gäbe
es weiterhin eine deutliche mehr der
deutschen die sagen lieber Herr Harbig
die Ziele ja aber bitte so nicht
manchmal die Bildzeitung deshalb die
Frage den Schritt dann zu nehmen AFD zu
wählen ist ja dann noch mal nein aber
wir haben jetzt ein guter analysiert die
Befindlichkeiten das abgehängt dann
fühlen der der Frust über Entscheidungen
der Bundespolitik die nicht mein
Lebensgefühl drin ich bin ganz bei Ihnen
verloren das klinikgesetz könnte die
noch das neue heizungsgesetz werden es
ist wirklich ein dramatischer Problem
wenn wir am Schreibtisch in Berlin
Entscheidungen treffen die entweder in
der eigenen Wohnung in dem Haus oder
jetzt vielleicht im ländlichen Raum auch
mal eben von oben sagen dieses Klinik
diese Klinik brauchen wir dann nicht wir
haben ja eine zehn Kilometer weiter das
ist ein wirkliches Problem auf der
anderen Seite sind wir natürlich auch in
einer Krise oder in vielen Krisen wo
bestimmte auch schmerzhafte
Entscheidungen getroffen werden müssen
und ja ich sag nur ja aber gemacht wir
haben bei der Energiekrise doch harte
gute gut erklärte Maßnahmen getroffen
die Deutschen waren relativ froh dass
der Winter so glücklich aufgehört und
dann kommt er mit dem nächsten Ding um
die Ecke und jetzt kommt er Lauterbach
mit dem nächsten Ding um die Ecke die
überfordern dieses Land diese Politik
überfordert das Land das ist das Problem
Lauterbach im Interview sagt die tauchen
dann in den Rettungsstationen auch wo
sie nichts zu suchen haben wo ich denke
ja weil
da ja
das fühle ich sehr stark also es geht um
das Schließen von Geburtskliniken und so
das ist einfach er hat Gutach Moment
aber sie sind in meiner Meinung nicht
nicht überzeugt und nicht gut genug und
das geht jetzt genauso los das gleiche
Theater frau Lorenz dann gucken wir mal
ganz kurz nach vorne in den letzten zwei
Minuten was passiert oder was ist denn
wenn in dem wenn im nächsten Jahr
nächsten Herbst und drei Landtagswahlen
in Ostdeutschland gibt Sachsen
Brandenburg und Thüringen wenn da die
AFD jeweils stärkste Partei wird was
wird sich dann noch mal ganz extrem
etwas ändern oder was denken Sie was
dann kommt
tja das weiß glaube ich keiner so
richtig wie es da weitergeht Oma
vielleicht ein neues neuen Vorschlag in
die Debatte einzubringen wir haben ja
sehr ähnlich polarisierte Stimmungen in
den Gesellschaften in unseren
Nachbarländern in anderen
potenzialistischen Räumen und ähnliche
Schwierigkeiten deshalb dort auch
manchmal Koalitionen zu bilden und dort
gibt es ja manchmal beamtenregierung
also Expertinnen und Experten da ist
dann überhaupt gar keine Partei mehr
vertreten das wäre sogar einigermaßen
repräsentativ für Ostdeutschland
so wenig Menschen in Parteien sind und
dann würde man mit wechselnden
Mehrheiten
regieren also diese Idee die hat man
noch selten funktioniert
in Tschechien und jetzt gerade auch in
der Slowakei einigermaßen okay auf Zeit
auf Zeit da sind sie ganz dagegen nein
das wäre sozusagen wie die Grünen schon
notverordnungspolitik genau das wollen
wir nicht weil wir auch den
Parlamentarismus damit entfernt werden
das will ich überhaupt nicht sondern da
müssen sich die Parteien und die
Parlamente schon zusammenraufen dass sie
zu tragfähigen und mehrheitsfähigen und
durchsetzungsfähigen Regierungen kommen
okay wir sind gespannt vielen Dank für
die Diskussion auch dann wenn wir das
Problem natürlich noch nicht gelöst
haben Frau Meier Herford vielen Dank
Frau Lorenz für die Zuschaltung vielen
dank ihnen fürs Interesse morgen sind
wir wieder für Sie da dann schauen wir
natürlich anlässlich des EU-Gipfels noch
mal auf Russland und auf die
Entwicklungen dann entsprechend in der
Ukraine bis dann
[Musik]